well tonight a behind-the-scenes look to
one of the health district's
mega vaccination sites this one is at
the las vegas convention center which is
right near desert inn
and paradise now it opens tomorrow and
that's where we find sally jaramillo
joining us now live with
what you can expect if you need to go
there for your second dose sally
[Music]
denise while this was just a sneak peek
there was also
a few nurses who were getting their
second vaccine and as you can imagine
they tell me they're feeling
extremely relieved that they finally got
it they're also very excited with how
the process
is panning out the vaccine just arrived
sarah lugo is the senior community
health nurse for the southern nevada
health district
she says the main concern right now is
having the public understand the first
dose
and second dose are given out in
different locations
we're going to be doing second dose cova
19 vaccines at convention center
specifically for anyone to receive the
first dose at one of the southern nevada
health districts
or at one of our community partners
sites those community partners
she's talking about include cashment
center mac middle school
and western high so once you make your
appointment here at the convention
center
bring that cdc immunization card if they
do not have that cdc immunization card
they'll be checked into nevada web ic to
check which vaccine they receive
and look if the dose interval dates are
correct once approved you will be sent
to the modern
or pfizer site to start the process then
they'll come
through and they'll go right over we
have red over here is our pfizer side
blue is our modernized and they'll be
able to walk right over to the nurses
station
get their vaccine walk right behind them
to the observation station
we'll be observed for 15 to 30 minutes
jessica johnson is a registered nurse
who just received her second dose
i thought everything was great the
different colors to keep people separate
make sure you're getting the right
vaccine
the nurses were great if i had any
questions they would have helped me out
and it was just really easy
here at 8 news now we have received many
questions regarding the vaccine now the
southern nevada health district wants to
remind everyone to please be patient new
information keeps coming out
and it will continue to inform us as for
the hours of operation
here they will be from tuesday through
saturday 8 30 a.m
through 3 30 p.m reporting live sally
jaramillo
8 news now